what i want to do in this video is give
ourselves an introduction or an
intuition for the term flux in general
and then think about how it applies to
the idea of magnetic
magnetic flux
so first of all when people are just
talking about flux and this is the
easiest way that i know how to
conceptualize it they're talking about
how much of something is flowing through
a surface in a given amount of time so
if you imagine that this is this is you
know i'm just defining a volume of air
right over here and let's say the air is
denser near the near the bottom of this
volume of air so there's more air
down here than there is up here which is
generally true air density goes down as
as the as you increase altitude so
there's very low density up here this is
in between i don't have to draw all of
the air particles but you get the sense
a lot of air a lot of air down here
and the air is moving and so let's say
that the air let's say the air is
so this we do the velocity vectors in a
different color so
these are some of the velocity vectors
of
the air let's say the air on this side
is moving
at say a medium velocity
so right
over there but as we move more in that
direction the air the air is moving
faster so they have a they have larger
larger velocity vectors like that
we see that in general all of the air is
moving in that general direction that's
the way i'm drawing it and i can draw
the velocity vectors over here the air
is less dense
but the trend in the velocity vector
when i go from the left to the right is
roughly the same
so that's the flow
now i'm just sampling some velocity
vectors there so let's talk about flux
and to think about flux really of any
form you have to think about a surface
so let's imagine you were to put some
type of a net
let's say you were to put a net right
over
right over here
right over here and if we were to think
about the flux we would say well how
much air is traveling through that net
in a certain amount of time we could say
how many molecules are traveling in say
each second and so this would have some
flux associated with relative the air
but what if we were to take that same
net and we're assuming it's some type of
a theoretical net that actually does not
impede the air the air flow but it
allows us to it helps us visualize a
surface what if we were to move that net
a little bit to the right
where the density is the same but the
particles are just moving faster
well now our flux would increase
so this is larger flux
larger
larger flux why is our flux increase
because well the density is the same but
in any given amount of time i'm going to
have more things going through that
surface
now what if i were to put take that same
net and move it up to this high altitude
right over here
that high altitude well the velocity is
of the molecules are the same and
they're going in the same direction but
there's just fewer of them so you're
going to have less fewer molecules
traveling through the surface in a given
amount of time so this is going to have
smaller flux and this is all relative to
my first one
smaller
smaller flux
now what if you were to take the same
net and instead of the air going perpend
the direction of the air being
perpendicular to the surface being
normal to the surface what if you were
to take the net and and reorient it so
that the air is going in the same
direction of the surface so what if you
were to take the same net and you were
to make it like this
so that it's the same that i know it
doesn't look exactly the same but it's
the same net
and you're to make it like this well now
how much air is traveling through that
net in a given amount of time
well now very little to zero air is
going to be traveling through that net
in a given amount of time the air is
going along the surface not through the
surface so this one we could say this
let's just say that all the air is going
exactly in the same direction as the
surface so nothing is going through the
surface we would say that this one has
zero
zero flux
now let's say this this net this
theoretical net that actually does not
impede the air flow let's say we can
stretch it or contract it so if we
stretch that net
in the same let's say we were to do it
let's say we were to stretch it up like
this
so it becomes a bigger net
so it becomes a bigger net like this
well now this thing is going to have
larger flux because there's just more
area there's more to flow through
so now if you said for this surface
you're going to have a larger flux
because there's just going to be more
air is going to go through that in a
given unit of time so as you can see
when we think about how much of
something just flux in the traditional
sense how much of something goes through
a surface in a given unit of time it
depends on the in in this case the
density of the substance it depends on
its velocity both the magnitude of the
velocity and the direction of the
velocity we see if we orient the surface
or if we oriented the velocity
so it's not going
normal to the surface perpendicular to
the surface well then we could have our
flux go down and you could have things
in between you could have a net
let's say we took that same original net
but the direction of the air is neither
normal nor exactly in the same direction
of the surface well this flux is going
to be in between is going to be in
between that original flux and this one
right over here there is going to be air
flowing through
there is
going to be air
flowing through
the actual surface but it's not going
exactly normal to the surface and as we
will explore later when we get a little
bit more mathy into it we actually care
about the component of the vector of the
air that is exactly normal when we
eventually calculate flux but this flux
is going to be someplace in between this
one and the zero flux because the area
isn't going exactly perpendicular
well that's just the general the the
more basic or the for me the more
intuitive notion of flux but what do we
mean by magnetic
by magnetic flux
well
like regular flux we're still dealing
with how
how things are kind of you could say
going through a surface but instead of
thinking about air particles or water
molecules or things like that we're
going to be thinking about a magnetic
field so let me draw a surface
so i have a i have a little bar magnet
this is the this is the north side this
is the south side we see our field lines
and then i've drawn a couple of the
magnetic field vectors in white there
and let's say that we have a surface
we have a surface like this
and so for this surface when we think
about the flux
we want to care about how much we're not
actually things are actually actually
moving when we think about magnetic flux
we aren't actually thinking about actual
physical things moving through this
surface the way we did when we thought
about i guess you could say traditional
or more or flow-based flux but it's a
similar idea we care we care about the
component of the magnetic field and the
density of the magnetic field that is
normal to this surface so let's say that
this has a given flux
so let's call that and the notation is
phi and i'll say that's the flux of the
magnetic field
and once again it's based on
it's based on the strength of the
magnetic field
and especially the component of the
magnetic field vectors
that are perpendicular
that are perpendicular to this actual
surface so this would have one magnetic
flux but if i were to take the same
surface and make it parallel
make it parallel to the
to the magnetic field vectors instead of
being normal or now the magnetic field
vectors are parallel to n instead of
being normal so now our flux is zero so
this would have zero or pretty close to
zero so approximately zero
magnetic flux
flux now if i were to take this surface
and instead of orienting this way i just
moved it further away
so instead of putting here i were to
take it all the way out here where the
magnetic field where the magnetic field
is weaker
where the magnetic field is weaker so we
have a weaker magnetic field out here
the flux would also decrease so it has a
lot of the same properties as this more
physical flux that we were talking about
before but instead of talking about say
the velocity of the air molecules we're
talking of the velocity vectors of the
air molecules and how those relate to
the surface here we're talking about the
the
magnetic field vectors and how that
those relate to the surface but the the
metaphor the analogy is is still the
same if they are perpendicular you have
larger flux if they are if they are
going in the same direction you might
have zero or very little you might have
very little flux if you have a weak
magnetic field out here the flux is
going to be lower than if you have a
strong then if you have a strong
magnetic field that's analogous to when
you had high density and high velocity
that was a lot of flux versus low
density or low velocity that is lower
flux and also we could increase the
total surface
so if we stretch that surface or we had
a larger surface right over here the
flux through this surface is going to be
larger than the flux through this
surface let's say this surface is
analogous to a surface like this right
over here let's say that the magnetic
field is symmetric on both sides so this
the flux through this surface and this
surface would be the same so if you were
to stretch it out to have a to be a
larger surface well now you just have
more your you have more of the magnetic
field that is now normal to the surface
so hopefully this gives you at least a
beginning ideas of of the notion of
magnetic flux and how it relates to i
guess you can think of more physical
flux